i'm telling you i don't know what it is
my head just
it's full of secrets
i'm gretchen weiner's for mean girls
it's full of secrets and that's why it's
so big but i cannot wear average sized
hat can you tell when it's raining too i
no i can't tell when it's raining i
can't tell when somebody is laundering
money
[Music]
uh my name is chappelle
that's cat that's chin that's [ __ ]
nick that's a [ __ ] nick and that's a
meatball and we are cats after dark yes
we are
episode
13 14 14 this is 18. oh [ __ ] none of us
know yeah this is episode 18.
jesus what what
you sure yeah because we did we did we
did one episode then we had 16 magic
mind episodes yeah and now we start a
new 16 magic mind episodes because they
renewed
magic thank you you know what let's
let's start it off with it yeah we
should uh we have this episode going
is the wheel here what a perfect time
for the wheel next uh only three of us
get them today i need to okay
yeah i feel like it's more bruce willis
and uh hunger games
oh it's good i love it i brought a wheel
to a bachelor party this weekend and it
came in handy there you go
i'll be super focused for this episode
yeah so i kind of hope it does
god i need one today
chappelle chappelle
you get a magic mind oh okay you get a
match of mine you get it george's gonna
throw you one
last
magic mine is involved i will catch it
eye coordination i don't know what it is
i don't know how i caught that one
because
i love the brightness thank you probably
the lion's mane mushroom and what about
the ashwagandha
ashwagandha it's beautiful this time of
year
it was like
that's good
my bad
i like this so much more than the juice
shots because i used to take the uh like
ginger turmeric ones but this goes down
so much easier so much easier it's so
much better tasting
and everybody else can try it and see
what they're talking about and i'll give
you more at magicmind.com
promo code for 25 percent
promo code
[Music]
i'm always saying the promo code dark
you have to be the designated that's for
me yeah that's right why though
chappelle why do we why i'm just asking
are you questioning why i'm asking why
does he have to be the one that's [ __ ]
up our name this is this show should be
called cat next to dark
[Music]
my cat just said it every time you dab
me up i feel like we're that meme of
like the black hand the white hand oh
yeah oh yeah the super buff forearms
yeah i think that's this is this
no no no there it is yeah
that's what it is that's us but also
another badass white arm though badass
white yellow shout out
shout out to magic mine dog shout out to
magic mine shout out ashwagandha shout
out
uh
at
adaptations you got this bro we've seen
the analytics we're moving some product
for this company i want to talk to
someone who's bought it send in your
receipt and we'll zoom you in yeah send
your stuff in let me know what you guys
think you know your uh what do they call
that not a review testimonial yeah it's
like a church yeah come on and testify
yeah good yeah make sure you gotta have
the holy spirit of magic mike
send your video to what to wear uh cats
after dark gmail.com yeah send your
videos to cats after dark gmail.com give
us your testimonies make sure you have a
podium make sure you have a robe on
because we want to hear you preach
now tell us about london
yes
it's going down in london oh it's going
down
yeah i think that's my first home yeah i
think it's my second home yeah
yeah don't tell uh john millen camp that
but
yeah because i don't want to get mad but
yeah that's me at the tower of london
uh you in that shirt i know i love that
shirt i love that shirt dude someone the
best comment was this dude it's at the
top of the
i pinned it gosh where is it on this one
yeah it pinned it
he goes uh
gosh what does it not show pinned
comments or anything maybe try to
refresh it
try uh
no no
i remember when you go on the computer i
remember what he said the guy goes oh
man i thought that was idris elba
oh yeah oh my god that's the best
compliment that's the best comment ever
elba is so old and then everyone said i
didn't know london had a bunch of floods
because of my pants
[Laughter]
oh no it was dude i
actually that was my first time overseas
yeah first time you know
traveling over there like because i've
i've been to canada in mexico but that
was my first time you know
flying over the pond or the pond yeah
yeah
and uh i don't know i just learned so
[ __ ] much yeah just like seeing a
different culture what was that nature
the one thing that stood out to you the
most being over there
this may sound crazy
but i i didn't feel any tension out
there
do you feel tension here yes in
comparison all the time what do you mean
you know where we live
i don't know if that makes any sense but
like it just seemed a little bit more
relaxed a little more chill
uh
i don't know it was one of my favorite
parts the funniest parts i was at this
concert right i once saw liam gallagher
shouts out liam gallagher and uh
first of all i was wrong i said i said i
saw him play to a hundred thousand
people it was 80 000. okay he sold 160
000 tickets that's what he sold because
he played two nights so i thought i was
seeing it 800 same yeah
but anyway
but i just want to correct that shout
out across wisconsin but uh
so these dudes were standing next to me
they're like they obviously knew i was
american by the way i was dressed and
all that [ __ ] they're like what what
brings you here and i was like oh i'm
here to see liam and uh
and i thought they were gonna be like
okay
i thought they're gonna be like uh
oh oh there's black people that like
liam or something like no they were like
oh we didn't know people from the states
like liam yeah that was like interesting
because usually that's what i hear on
the regular basis like oh i don't know
black dudes like blah blah blah blah
blah but over there i didn't really hear
anything
of that nature it was kind of cool yeah
i i heard that
if you go over to the uk they don't
really care as much about race but they
do care about class it's more classist
than anything else yeah yeah yeah so
there's some very posh i heard it's not
good to be posh it's not good i heard
it's embarrassing i don't know i didn't
learn that yet yeah you know when i go
back there though first trip yeah
yeah first first year
first trip that just means you aren't
posh then do this which might be a good
thing i will you know what else i love
is how much they bust balls yeah they
and they do it in such a clever way like
okay so jay because i went with jay
shout out to jay shop he went yeah
that's yeah that's one thing on about my
bone i want to pick with him because you
guys have been together you guys are
there but none of you guys took pictures
together dude you're on your instagram
because they have to take the photo for
each other yeah okay
i always get people to take pictures of
myself you know you know one thing i
hate taking pictures
yeah yeah they take videos okay fine i
like enjoying the moments that's some
cool spots where i was like okay i'll
take a picture of this but uh
uh shouts out jay jay but it was funny
because after the concert we were
leaving the concert j wanted jay was
going to use the restroom
the lou and uh he was washing his hands
and he had a bunch of like soap like
soap studded up yeah and this guy looks
at me goes you're getting ready for
surgery
[Laughter]
but that's how they like bust balls
there but it's just like dry and like
clever and funny like that but it was it
was a great time we went everywhere it
was cool to be i went to manchester
which is where oasis is from which was
really [ __ ] cool um the queen's
jubilee was going on how was it when i
was down there that [ __ ] was crazy
crazy
yeah it was a big deal out there big
deal i love the food hey [ __ ] everybody
that says their food what did you eat
what did you eat
um i had their
it's like what what's like our two egg
breakfast you know we have the two oh
they're like full english breakfast
right
eggs the beans the tomatoes
tomatoes did you have blood sausage
did you have the sausage no no because i
did the vegan okay yeah
but but i thought it was good as [ __ ]
yeah i i wasn't complaining at all i'm
trying to think of where else we we
pretty much ate like all did you eat
bangers and mash
it's like sausage and then uh
mashed potatoes no
was it this yeah
you probably had some mash yeah so i
thought you did vegan yeah i did the
vegan well eggs aren't vegan
no they had it it was tofu scrambled oh
okay yeah yeah so he's a vegan of that
or whatever that we ate at this place
called greg's which has a which is kind
of like a
like a kind of
where was there a spot out here it's
called greg's
what type of food is this do you know
where it's kind of like almost fast
foodie uh drugs with two g's
i think i got it dude hey i was sending
cat videos oh my god just out of nowhere
like videos and live photos of himself
on the [ __ ] train
with a bad english accent
he was so excited to be
in london it was
so cute it's like a kid going to
disneyland for the first time like his
text messages
his photos oh dude he was having the
time of his life
that's why i said it's my first time
we're having a whole first home
chappelle really said man's not hot
oh yeah
pickups
do they they uh hold on
oh this one's pretty good i don't know
if i sent this one
uh send you another one christian look
at that's me on the tube i love when
people send me photos of themselves and
they don't realize that it's a live
photo because i'll press play oh my gosh
i remember telling stevie that now he's
self-conscious so he will only send me
regular photos it won't be live anymore
i was telling i was telling jay i was
like yo take a picture right now because
you can hear him in the background i
just like felt it it's like a second or
two yeah it was it was like oh this is a
good one
i think i think i have it down i think
maybe we might have sitting outside
it's solid manchester um
to an american ear in sauron tower in
london
[Laughter]
what do you think don't lie
it was good in the first part yo first
of all you were racist you're like you
sound jamaican in the first in that
first video you're saying you did it
that doesn't sound jamaican doesn't
sound english to me
don't you make fun of my first home ever
how is jay over in london because i know
he's like
he's half british correct yeah they they
are yeah yeah so did he have any like
family over there he went to go see your
like any level spots he recommended
while you guys were there uh no because
we pretty much just chilled well j yeah
actually jay knew a lot of this stuff
dude you know what was [ __ ] jay also
knows everything was being recognized
out there
there's people that literally running
out of restaurants with oh my god
chappelle lacy you're like what hell
yeah out here yeah cause i did a show
i did a show i actually i performed at
like a legendary punk rock club
in london where like sex pistols have
played like all these [ __ ] you know
great punk rock fans and uh it was kind
of cool like they they [ __ ] [ __ ] with
our comedy heavy they love american
comedy really yes and like i love theirs
yeah i know i love theirs too so it's
kind of it's kind of dope but but they
also they take comedy
seriously as it is no as it is no like
like as far as like being an audience
member
like they take comedy as like yeah
that's it's a joke
i don't know that's what i just felt the
whole time because i have this joke that
uh i do about my abusive stepfather
right and sometimes when i do it out
here
it like [ __ ] people just like oh my
god how could you you know what i mean
like how how could you say such things
but
i mean i don't want to step on your [ __ ]
i just listened to a lot of spell lacey
this morning oh yeah he was telling me
about this check it out below the line
he's telling me uh amazing stuff because
you sounded too angry because you
thought you were mad at your father and
you had to do some introspection and
like why am i feeling it yeah you really
did listen
to it he said he got emotional too he
got emotional but that's true though
cause like and but but when i did when i
did that joke out there
it was the hardest it ever hit it was
insane like every [ __ ] line every
[ __ ] thing i said of that joke people
were just [ __ ] with that's awesome it
was it was [ __ ] crazy oh yeah
that damn it i tried it [ __ ] it i yeah i
performed at the 100 club
you know what rehearse it a little bit
more you're trying your best you know i
think i rush yes you got to slow down
you got to slow it down breathe
in the middle of these words
that's why i only say that's only one i
only sent like six second videos yeah
because i was like if i say too many
words they'll know i'm american
they'll be like no you're not from here
and i'm like no i am though
did you
get a show scheduled and then just find
out that liam was there or did you were
you going to see liam and you're like
i'm going to try to get a yeah no no i
wasn't even trying to get a show my
agents were like hey do you want to
perform out there and i was like hey why
not yeah and i was like don't book me
like something big cause i was like i
don't know how many
fans i got out there dude there was a
guy that [ __ ] drove 100 miles
so [ __ ]
so he had his kids miles are kilometers
he wrote miles okay got him see he knows
what he's eating he knows what it is if
he said 100 km i'm like what dog
i don't even know what that means but uh
he drove a hundred miles
to come and take a picture with me
because
he had his kid with him yeah and he
wouldn't let his kid in his kid was like
five years old and they wouldn't let
they wouldn't let him in or whatever
yeah and so he [ __ ] drove he goes he
goes he reached out to me on instagram
he goes hey this is this may be a long
shot but i have my kid they won't let my
kid in i just want to take a picture
with you i live 100 miles away is it
okay if i drive down and you know do you
think i would get the chance to meet you
and take a picture with you i was like
one thou i wrote back immediately it was
like yeah
huh yeah yeah it was it was cool though
like he just [ __ ] there was one and
they gave me gifts
too they they give you gifts what kind
of gifts yeah one dude
i know right he made a wallet for me oh
my god that's an amazing yeah one dude
uh probably this like a live
uh oasis uh or sorry liam gallagher what
are you looking at
i was
i was seeing
yeah and then i was seeing if
you probably have manual tags on so no i
turned off my tags i don't like people
yeah that's why i was saying that's why
i was clicking on this to see how long
ago it was uh what was i saying though
before he made you a liam something oh
yeah he brought me like a uh liam did
this like live
show on uh on a boat or whatever
somewhere out there and uh
he got me like the cd of it but he it
was another guy he ran out of the
restaurant he was like oh my god he goes
he goes for my birthday i said i wanted
to i want to see chappelle lacy but he
wants to see like the whole crew right
and then uh he goes then i found out you
were coming here he was like it was the
most amazing thing ever
came to the show they were great they
were great man they're just i don't know
there's just great people out there
i i don't know there's something about
the i think that's the power of uh
travel like yeah i think we travel a lot
but a lot of people travel because the
place is beautiful but when you like
actually learn
about what what you're what you're in
and like just around the train and
writing you know they call it the tube
but writing writing all that [ __ ] and
like just seeing kind of regular folk
and just
i don't know just visiting like immerse
yourself into that culture yeah yeah you
just learn a lot you know
yeah jay knew [ __ ] everything yeah
like if i didn't have jay
oh
i would have been [ __ ] lost he was he
was the [ __ ] best dude he just had it
all locked out he goes we'll take the
tube here it'll take us here blah blah
blah blah blah blah he knew everything
yeah and he's a big lewis hamilton fan
and we got we wouldn't ate at his uh
uh restaurant or whatever there's a
restaurant yeah he's a vegan restaurant
down in soho because he's vegan or
whatever not jay but uh yes
hamilton louis yeah you you didn't know
who he was
yeah i had to ask i was up it was on the
tip of my attention
that's like jay's f1 right they said he
said there's not too many people he
would geek out over of meeting but he
said [ __ ]
uh lewis hamilton is the one lewis
hamilton is is his oh it's coming at the
u.s
his food chain
oh it is
i've heard that yeah game changer
that's a cool title yeah yeah it was
good or a cool name for pictures you uh
and most of them it looked like it blew
skies which completely went against 50
and cloudy yeah exactly no it was uh we
lucked out we had pretty much had some
the whole time except for the last day
we were there mm-hmm
it was like you were leaving then yeah
yeah yeah i know thank god i gotta go i
don't know it was kind of wild because
the jubilee was over yeah
there's so much to [ __ ] talk about i
can go on all day but the wild thing is
is so many people were like inviting me
to their towns or whatever they're like
come here come here they're like my my
uh nan is what they say
cookie or whatever whatever like cook
like food for me or whatever
and honestly i almost took these
[ __ ] up on their offers because
i was like you know it's so nice here
and i don't feel like it i feel like
people genuinely just want to yeah hang
out you know but i was just like there's
a lot of traveling
to like these you know hopping on the
trains and stuff like that it sounds
like you're studying abroad it's really
cute and you have like that's why your
parents abroad yeah look after you you
know man it's it's it's wild
they have a big uh knife problem out
there though yeah there's a lot of
stabbings yeah a lot of knives yep it's
like they're it's like our gun problems
they do like public service stuff
what'd you say they do public
we're talking about idris elba you look
like uh there i do it yourself how to
make a public service announcement about
like can we stop the knife stabbing
violence yeah
i guess
the knife stabbing violence yeah
yeah like isn't the soccer game or the
football games out there like the they
get like that's where the gangs go and
like battle
the hooligans
i was talking i was talking to them
about that they said it's not as crazy
as it like used to be they said it used
to be a lot crazy i think that's because
they want to go watch football but they
just enjoy
doing doing [ __ ] they enjoy like
i mean this one dude tried to pick me up
at the gallagher concert then he
realized oh this guy's a lot bigger than
i thought
he was like
but that's how they are you know they
put each other on each other's shoulders
and like you know i don't know it's like
i don't know how to explain it they're
like a little rowdier more like like
rowdy but full of life and it's it's all
about high spirits high spirits and
great energy yeah it's not about like oh
i'm here to be tough or
i i just didn't feel those vibes
you know when i go to some shows or
whatever
or just being out here a lot you feel
you just feel tension naturally i mean
yeah we have a lot of crazy [ __ ] here
you know it's [ __ ]
i don't know
so yeah i moved there next
week
we're zooming in every week yeah yeah
we'll see i'll zoom in every week
yeah you'll catch me at piccadilly
circus every day
yeah so yeah shout out to the queen
shout out she didn't invite me but
she didn't invite uh kim or pete either
apparently yeah repeat just got denied
yeah you don't see the the jubilee said
go hang out with the queen i heard
that's a fake rumor and they weren't
actually on their way there oh it was a
fake room yeah that's oh it wasn't real
oh because they came out they're like
yeah we were there but like we weren't
trying to go to the jubilee we were just
in london oh see people are haters dude
who would just be making up [ __ ] see
they don't do that down in london
i'm gonna get better at this [ __ ]
accent i swear to god
i swear to god
what did you guys do man
i went to san jose for about 36 hours
for a baby shower and it's so weird
shout out baby yeah shout out to the
baby shower it's so weird now that i'm
old enough where people are having
children and getting married and going
back to my hometown everyone is such an
adult and i feel like such a nuisance
because they're like oh like they work
in hr they own their own businesses
they're doing like adult [ __ ] and then
they ask me what i'm like oh
i feel like what i do isn't real
it when you see people like
working regular [ __ ] yeah not saying i
mean whatever when you see people
working regular [ __ ] you just look at
yours and goes like what the [ __ ] am i
doing yeah it's a bit different yeah
it's also so nice i
i feel like i don't go out and see
people very much when i'm here in la so
going back home i feel like i see
everybody in my social battery just gets
diminished so quickly but it's nice to
just be around people
in the industry it's so nice that's a
good feeling because everyone in l.a
kind of works in the industry in one way
or another that's right that's a bad one
that's when he goes back to [ __ ]
lacrosse i was in palm springs for a
bachelor party with all wisconsin guys
this weekend and they're gonna build a
[ __ ] statue for this man they really
are if they don't i will
i know the crosswalk i will sponsor
someone too there was like a statue of
nick a comfortability with like yeah
yeah no [ __ ]
well you don't have to think about any
of this [ __ ] and i was on my i was like
on my phone more than like anybody else
and stuff and i was i was trying to be
like i saw you oh yeah
dude that was crazy i did a five fight
parlay
400 win five grand yeah
all everybody tailed like no one's
really like as fanatic as i was the
fifth fight was a guy from wisconsin and
we're we're like all like edge of your
seat like everybody's gonna win big and
it was saturday afternoon because the
fight started at 10 so this is like
2 30 in the afternoon where poolside and
the dude from wisconsin wins us all
money it was incredible really yeah it
was awesome and as he was knocking him
out
you someone should pull this up uh nor
mcdonald's uh betting advice
uh
he
i'll kind of ruin it but it's really
funny when he says it right to manny
pacquiao his advice for betting on
fights is always better on the bigger
blacker guy
and i said that i will always bet on you
i said this as like i'm like his advice
always better on the bigger knockout i
was like oh my god and we also this is a
black dude oh yeah yeah oh day osborne
from milwaukee's
uh
oh there it is
this shit's so funny classic norm he
says it right to manny pacquiao before
his fight with floyd mayweather
what was pacquiao's reaction
uh well he lost
yeah he lost yeah he lost that fight
he's like that's fair he might be bigger
than floyd too though i think he's
bigger yeah yeah yeah so it doesn't
necessarily yeah
maybe it won't come up but i think i
think manny is but i mean
and all those dudes came in from
wisconsin yeah uh they're kind of all
over the country but most of them accept
one i think is from wisconsin but yeah
some live in denver some live in arizona
oh okay yeah i i was the only one that
came from california though oh god i got
it it was a blast
uh are you going to the wedding yep mine
it's in montana i'm gonna wear a bolo
type
what's a bolo tie like uh cowboy the
string cowboy oh gotta gotta got it
independent oh you gotta oh you're gonna
get right it's it's it's wes it's
western western yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that's how it's not themed like a theme
party but it's like it's just gonna be a
little bit okay
yeah
that sure is
yeah uh i went to one i think
i went to one bachelor party
two i've been to two
and i hated it
i feel like bachelor parties are so
different from like person to person
yeah some people want to go camping for
a weekend some people want to do like
the vegas route yeah i went to i went to
vegas for one got it and then the other
one was just in dallas
uh
but yeah the vegas one
i remember this first time i did an
edible
and this is before they had the
controlled edibles where it was like 10
mil but before they started doing oh
here's 10 milligrams of edibles no no
you took the edible where you said jesus
take the wheel yeah it was uh i think it
was like 150. it was my first time
man that i puked my [ __ ] brains we
were supposed to go see the jabbawockeez
it was [ __ ]
tough i can't believe i [ __ ] did that
why would you go see the jab walk he's
granted i'm also saying this as like
my uncle manages the jabberwock and i'm
saying this
listen i love those they're dope but why
would you
he said i mean cheerleading dance i
could see the yeah
i love the [ __ ] could you you
obviously you could but like
right now they they're a different level
of what uh what i can do but could you
look who will break dancing
i know i think if you put some time and
effort into it you could break down you
better absolutely yeah
maybe an hour
yes
hey give me give me three give me three
weeks in uh england and i bet you you'd
never think i was from america tell you
that much yeah i'll have that [ __ ]
accent down i was doing all right you
know but anyways shouts out john
milwaukee shout out to john uh shout out
to 150 milligrams uh
they're so dope they are
and it's really cool because they have
the uh mask you can switch people in and
out it was like the blue man group where
you don't know so the legacy of the jab
walk jab walkies gets to live on mm-hmm
i love that i can do this in the shower
yeah yeah that's where i move
shout out shouts out to chin can break
dance too
can you no
no no
remember he was in a r b group and the
only reason why he didn't do it because
he didn't want dancing he didn't want to
dance no i still did the group but but
they all wanted to do dances
i said i'm going to quit the group if we
had to do dances so we're going to do
dance
you're a diva hey jj
eva got to dance that was the first time
chin showed up to work in a neck brace
it's not because i don't want to do it
it's just because it hurts too much dude
i can't wait to see the vh1 behind the
music for this
[ __ ] i i said i will not yeah i can't
do this group if we dance and at the
beginning they give you like a little
like sizzle reel of it and it's just
like it goes black and white like doom
zoom yep they were on a high temperature
yeah i wasn't gonna [ __ ] do i'll quit
the band
yeah so anyways that's that was bts or
whatever i can't remember was that the
name for the group i was trying to joke
that he quit a band that went on to
become super oh yeah yeah can you
imagine but bts you're like 20 years
younger than me so it doesn't make sense
yeah
you look you look 20. thank you bro i
don't believe you but thank you very
much
great skin
i do i remember who was shocked when
they heard your age yeah younger than
that yeah i thought you were really
excited that i'm 38 but it's just just
crazy your bones are a little rickety
now but you look great thank you i don't
know if you feel great like if i i mean
if you didn't tell me your age and you
had me guess only only based off your
wisdom i would think you were older than
me 35 older than 30 but i i would have
guessed like [ __ ]
like 37
you know only only based off your wisdom
but if you didn't if you didn't have no
[ __ ] wisdom like let's do 25 okay so
if you if you were a casualty
me and me you were a casper high school
boy you're casting like a film and
you're looking for like i don't know
like a high school guy or a guy in his
like early twenties would you cast chin
based off of looks
[Laughter]
that'd be funny just in high school
musical killing it right right randomly
yeah
chilling with ashley tisdale that wasn't
oh my gosh oh vanessa vanessa vanessa
no no she wasn't at all okay
shout out to brenda song though the
original abg it says rappel convinced me
though for her
it looks like it right now no she was on
tweet life of zach and cody she wasn't
she was on that but i don't know why i
thought she was in like a bunch of
disney movies yeah she was in a bunch of
disney movies she wasn't in high school
i just saw stuck in the suburbs
yeah stuck in the suburbs it was a
classic yeah what's that wait does is
she on the panel is she on the view the
view no that's uh jeannie um
if you don't dance you know what's funny
there's b-boys and there's gangsters by
the way okay you're right you're right
fair enough we had like an actual table
and i was invited by one of our friends
but they're all part of us they're part
of a church group a christian like
church group so that's how the friends
that you went to the club yeah
i know right
we're church group and we're gonna we're
gonna go to the club get a book but they
still
speaking of church people you know who's
on my flight who uh kurt cameron
what i love him yeah from growing pain
from growing pains yeah i need to see a
photo to know he seems like the sweetest
nicest guy mike seaver that guy yeah
mike's oh god it got it got it allen six
you know who else was on my [ __ ]
flight well on the show
you know who else oprah winfrey no 311
oprah winfrey 3 11. there's no way
so i had a layover in denver mm-hmm and
then from they were on my denver dude
show the picture oh i only took it with
uh essay and uh nick who's 311
oh my gosh are you serious i had to ask
you you've definitely heard their music
aging out yeah it is
but you probably heard their biggest
single which i can't even get in my head
ahead right now but what's the name of
it the biggest single uh
a lot but um
there's one song that was in a
a movie i think if you play it
is the color of yours
oh yes okay
do you know come original you got to
come already is that the name of song no
damn you don't know this [ __ ] uh do you
know down change a lot of them thumbs up
damn so we can't actually i think they
might have been like
everyone knows it you could listen to it
later you'll probably recognize it if
you have no actually he might he's too
young
cause you're too little
what is it little or young that's what
you think something is the color of your
energy yeah amber chamber amber is like
energy
i'm just i'm just not gonna vocalist
when it comes to singing like that do
you know the cure meatball
yeah you get a cover of the cure i will
always love you
have you heard that song i have to like
actually hear it to remember oh um hey
show the picture i stick with them
whenever i'm alone with you
there you go okay wow
oh damn it isn't it so well yeah it was
dope
so cool dude
they look good wow look at you and that
guy on the left matching dimples yeah oh
yeah
the lead singer what's his name
look at my [ __ ] chubby cheeks right
there you don't have chubby cheeks
because of the headphones
i feel like bucket hats usually make
people's heads look bigger oh it does
yeah i wore one too recently really yeah
yeah so i don't think the bucket hat
even though it looks good is doing you
any favors i got my feelings hurt in a
store right in the middle that she's
like even though it looks good
[Laughter]
the positive yeah compliments
even it out no because i i already know
i have a big head but i had my feelings
here in an lv store the other week when
i went with my mom because she wanted to
go look at a bag i saw a cool bucket hat
i was like i just wanted to try it yeah
i just want to try it on yeah so i tried
it and it got like to right here and i
was like oh i knew i had a big head but
god this is hurting my [ __ ] feelings
you just [ __ ] stopped
and the guy who was helping my mom the
like sales associate was like oh we
actually have two sizes this might be
the small one let me go see if i could
get the bigger one for you okay cool and
then he comes back like that's actually
the bigger one
he's like do you want to um i'm like no
it's fine
no no i'm cool
yeah and now i'm really embarrassed to
try on hats in public
well let's let's find cat a nice i can't
i can wear hats if they are men's sizes
do vietnamese she's my girlfriend does
she also have a big head and she's got a
huge headache yes she's got a huge head
we left uh excel some beautiful hat in
minneapolis yeah she's never found it in
an xl again i'm telling you i don't know
what it is my head just
it's full of secrets
i'm gretchen weiner's for mean girls
it's full of secrets and that's why it's
so big but i cannot wear average sized
hat can you tell when it's raining too i
no i can't tell when it's raining i
can't tell when somebody is laundering
money
that's hilarious that's the vibe that's
the like culturally
updated version of the gretchen wiener
got it
and are we about to see your picture
with kirk cameron you about to say you
chicken
i kind of chickened out and asking for a
picture because he just seemed kind of
to himself hey mike hey
where's boner oh my god how funny is
that that that that that that that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that that that bono was actual name yeah
this buddy yeah i didn't know that
actually huh i didn't know that in real
life you're saying that no no the
character oh yeah and they use it on
national tv yeah oh he names boner and
they call him boner constantly because
boner actually means like someone that's
like stupid or silly or something like
that
it's it's weird
yeah when i saw kirk cameron he's pretty
like gray but he still looks really
young yeah he has always weird like like
yeah all his hair is like gray but he
looks really young something he didn't
look like yeah he didn't look like old
or whatever
ricky schroeder ricky schroeder looked
young for the longest time
the
that was a kid that was in that uh
silver spoons but he looked like a kid
for the longest yeah
this is like old school stuff that most
people wouldn't even know
what no what was that movie he was in
was it the boxer
something like that yes
right fighter no the champion the
champion
where is it it's like the old ass old
ass movie
he was a child star so he kept looking
like a kid for a while his dad his dad
died spoiler for this movie
he's a great actor though yeah
yeah he does i'm assuming he dies in the
fight
yes because he's crying at the ring look
at him no you can't yeah is it his dad
i think it's his dad yeah or is it yeah
his grandpa dad man oh what'd you call
it john voight's in it too that's his
dad or scramble huh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah that is true yeah
yeah this is your voice yes holy that's
true yeah
you know who john boyd is yeah i love
him who's his daughter angelina jolie
right
right bro have you guys seen uh ray
donovan
i know what's amazing about i've seen it
no no no no it's on usa that
uh
drama yeah yeah he he was like the
father and ray donovan and he killed it
in that he's in a [ __ ] ton of uh he's an
anaconda yeah dude he's so funny in
anaconda like he's so about anaconda
that used to scare the [ __ ] out of me as
a kid ice cube's an anaconda yes he is i
think uh
it was such a stupid it was fun to watch
you know what [ __ ] that was like the
og sharknado in my opinion yeah but like
i think
well uh way better done yes
like more yeah sharknado is kind of
goofy
you know a movie i loved a lot because i
i just it made me think of jlo which jlo
made me think of salma hayek but i loved
uh from dusk till dawn oh that was the
one oh my god that scene keeps popping
up on my instagram page where
like a shot out of her foot
that was a fun movie but quentin
tarantino's character was freaking crazy
crazy like gross crazy him and clooney
dawg him and tony clooney was awesome
you know i was watching someone watch a
sandlot on the plane there was sandlot
yeah you look like sam up do i really in
that one photo with the shirt
that one kid
yeah the shortcut the chubby kid the
shirt the chubby kid i look like the
chubby kid is that what you said that's
why i thought she was yeah the the
original meatball what the what they
call them ham
hambone i forgot the names
i forgot i forgot those names the way
what do they call them
i'm sure you can
his name
he was in so many so many of those damn
movies as a kid big green big green
whatever he was looking busy oh he was
there's certain people like they have
such a crazy career as a child actor and
then they just disappear when they're
adults because they have access to the
money and they don't have to work
anymore
i'm afraid one time
what'd you say i met him on the street
one time in minneapolis he said patrick
yeah they were traveling
together
and showing sandlot in baseball stadiums
on the jumbotrons really yeah they were
like doing a tour oh it was for the
anniversary yeah yeah and uh he's like
yeah my girl's up in the uh we were like
i'm gonna drink with this she's like oh
my girl's up in the room waiting for me
oh damn okay yeah all right there you go
is it wendy
he's older but he still has a kid's face
right the same thing that we were
talking about before some people just
have kids faces yeah i get the exact
same face he just aged a little yeah
you can tell he's older but he has a
kid's style face i wonder how much money
that movie did in the box office that
was back when movies were doing like big
numbers big [ __ ] cuz you can only go
see something at a select few spots yeah
movies are only on tv now look up the
budget for it meatball because that's
always the the indicator i thought it
had it over there
when you see that budget
that's when you know that [ __ ] was oh
so they made it you know what killed it
in [ __ ] uh box office i don't even
realize it and people don't even like
that batman is uh
the george clooney one
yes
yeah that one killed the box wasn't that
the original um no
yeah
uh but that's the one with uma thurman
right as poison ivy
with clooney with clooney
and then arnold schwarzenegger as the
like iceman yeah yeah
the budget was 2125
and then it made
box office
cool
i think it says 160 mil
no that's a budget domestic gross is 100
no it was uh the one with val
valkyrie val kilmer oh shout out nick
yeah
the santa oh there he is
uh why'd you put three three things
because
uh because i was like this is like our
movie oh my god but then i'm pretty sure
there is a sandlot three three uh but
yeah that squeaks up front or squints
we've done this before we're on this
show luckily there's a patreon we almost
positive i'm having
mad day shopping right now but yeah look
how intensely my buddy todd is grabbing
squints
[Laughter]
six three six four i'm leaning big dude
yeah he's a big guy though
that's the [ __ ] todd looks like he knows
something that the rest of you guys
don't know that's why he's holding him
you know what else is crazy is
all of nick's friends are like big and
buff
we were all the land of the giants then
they come to l.a and [ __ ] tower over
[Laughter]
336 mil
for the val kilmer
valkyrie batman [ __ ]
you know what didn't do good at the box
office i was just telling them about
what you know that movie morbius with
jared leto oh yeah it did it so okay
here's the thing it came out maybe a
month or so ago and it bombed at the box
office it was supposed to be marvel's
like big next big like anti-hero jared
leto is a huge name they were hoping it
was gonna do well it bombed and then
there was a meme going around making fun
of how it bombed and nobody liked the
film
so much so i think the production
company or like the whoever produced it
was like you know what maybe we can do a
second release see if it does better
this time so they re-released it last
week and it bombed again so bombs at the
box office twice they probably got like
bad analytics being like man people are
talking about this quite a bit we gotta
try this again you know what you know
what well i see what i know why they
tried it again because a lot of times it
is timing yeah a lot of times like when
certain movies because uh i think we
talked about this last time when i
talked about uh the movie that martin
lawrence was in uh
blue sheep no not fire movie though the
night uh black knight
black knight
it was uh
a lot of it has to do with like timing
and when you release it and what's going
on around that weekend i don't know if
that's still prevalent today
[Laughter]
to help your
argument stranger things did come out
last week too so the second release was
going up against stranger things oh yeah
so you you're gonna realize who you're
going up against yeah yeah
kanye and drake did not release on the
same day yeah yeah
and and uh
50 and kanye did
and it did not do good for 50. yeah yeah
he wasn't he was supposed to retire i
guess he did you know he makes power
that was a tough job yeah i know yeah
right he's killing him
yeah he's fine and still a troll to
people
he's funny vitamin water effing vodka
yeah he has a bunch of [ __ ] yeah i
remember when people were trying to say
he was broke but he never was broken
but it's not he filed for bankruptcy in
order to avoid these people do that all
the time
you know who's not broke is mc hammer
though yeah i don't know hammer isn't
broken he is not broke that was always
the rumor that man said
dude
uh huh mister
man mr him 45. he said he would have a
man
oh really i did not when he first
started fighting yep
interesting emcee hammer yes
that's funny he's like he's like a
gangster
you didn't know this smart guy no
you're an mma guy i don't see him
i didn't know that at all oh but you you
knew that [ __ ] yeah i knew i knew it
from where you feel like that's such a
deep cut
yeah yeah it's kind of a deep cut
but yeah he is not broke that's a fun
little nugget yeah
i gotta see his roster yeah
i wonder if vanilla i still have money
oh he's female
oh yeah
he had he had a show on hgtv where he
was uh where are you the middle of high
school's amish uh
houses oh god i got it yeah he flips
houses or something i think because he
does construction himself yes
but to me if you're doing a show on hdv
that might be a sign you don't have
money why are you just are you missing
hgtv no you just need a paycheck i don't
like it there's more money just more
money yeah i guess
i'm not seeing emcee hammer vanilla
[Laughter]
i don't think vanilla ices and his
name's emcee hammer that man should be
fixing houses but look that's true
that's true that's true i just don't
know if vanilla ice is cute seasons
vanilla ice goes amish
that's a real thing oh wow i thought it
was way more did he go on rum springer i
heard that's a fun time no he's worth
more than 20. he's gotta be worth more
but i don't know yeah these things are
always not accurate it just gives like a
ballpark gotta be worth at least
200 million they said 50 was all right
who else
is a little too much
numbers dude
one
what
are
your
is like denzel or something 50 is only
at 30 million for that's like 15 20.
600. well that which is pretty much the
same i think denzel's more than 200
million because he has his own
production company as well yes you're
right make that money that money money
i love denzel
equalizer baby he came to my uh
girlfriend's work the other day
esop it's a skincare company
and that's it
strong name john washington two hundred
twenty-eight no yeah that's a lot wow i
think it's i think it might be more
though
i mean you got to realize denzel been
around
but
he's been around for 40 years
yeah
but you're not every role necessarily
how much money you have true
but i'm pretty sure he's got some in the
endeavors
you know what i'm trying to say yeah uh
he's probably got some things that we
don't know about
they're probably just going based off of
you know what they know yeah
i think i think he's i think he's
chilling yeah i mean even with 280 he's
showing up you know who still got mad
money too who eddie murphy oh yeah eddie
murphy have you seen his house in
beverly hills
it's like a big-ass compound
it makes it that makes sense i mean
he was getting orbit
one of my favorite characters of all
time
especially like the little when they uh
do that flashback to when they were a
kid that she's like you got a girlfriend
you do now get your ass up and hold my
hand i love that line oh my god i love
restrictions so much
millions
[ __ ]
do characters
like so good at it he's the asian guy
too like he's hilarious yes yes
he's killing ducks at the beginning
confession yeah never seen it oh i
thought you would please watch it it's
so good i thought it's something you
would have seen for sure terry crews is
in it black jack starts making its tits
dance it's great i feel like he does
that in literally every movie
every movie but uh
dude so i
heard this story about um andy murphy
for nutty professor so the family
they wanted to heil
heil they wanted to hire other actors
for the uh
for his family yeah dick uh for for his
family but but eddie was like no i'm
telling you i can play all these
characters he go and they were like no
we'll just we'll just you know we'll
audition audition a bunch of people and
but and then then he was like how about
i audition as every single character and
then you let me know
and then he auditioned as every single
uh one of his family members thank
goodness he did because it was freaking
incredible
he's more he was more upset that he got
a what does it actors get is oscars
uh oscars yeah for film yeah yes so for
whatever it is yeah for film he was he
was more upset that he got that he
didn't get one for this
but he got one for dream girls but
he was like man he goes from nutty
professor i play like all those kids all
these characters and he killed every
single comedy though yeah dude i mean
that's just comedy so much
harder to do than dramatic roles like
that was the only thing people struggled
with when i was in college and people
were doing like doing acting classes
like no one could get the
the comedy stuff down
and every like in every single acting
class you always learn that comedy is
the hardest profession to go in because
it's so hard to be funny some people
have some people don't
like being dramatic crying on cue is so
much easier than making someone laugh
yeah i i feel like comedy just doesn't
give like get it's
due diligence i don't know there's a lot
of it's delivery timing
i don't know there's just so much to it
yeah how you say [ __ ]
nor mcdowell says the key to comedy
surprise yep
you come the other way with it come the
other way with it
should we get some news from george yes
we got we got the news hey what's up
everybody
time well take it over to george i was
very aggressive last time when i didn't
get to do my job so i apologize we are
here now i i i sent them a text i was
like i used to pull news stories for
theo and i get really disheartened when
uh
but i was like if we if we leave stuff
on the table that's a good sign that
means shit's flowing so
shit's not flowing no let's go
i just don't want to hurt you yeah
all right so first off i just want to
say it's prince's birthday so we got to
give a little happy birthday to prince
one of the baddest [ __ ] of all
time friends i've been to um
they have that outfit in there too oh
that exact outfit yep
you feel you feel a wild energy when you
walk in not wild energy but you feel
like a
like a presence yes
he's got everything decorated in a
certain way it's kind of cool how old
would he be i'm 50 no 60 something right
he
to me prince doesn't mean he's 64. he
would have been 64.
damn and he died what 2014 sorry 2017.
2016.
2016. really
yeah oh i felt like i wasn't in l.a but
i guess i was yeah from fentanyl right
or something else yeah yeah i'm pretty
sure yep right there
yeah
what a crazy drug that is man
yeah cause he was so
he was in pain or something and he
was taking a painful i don't know what's
happening i get hit i get him and uh
michael jackson's death mixed up
michael jackson was 2009 but they were
the same age conrad they were they're
the same uh age when they passed not age
when they passed but same age in general
oh got it yeah so oh so michael would
also be 64
yeah yeah
because what
uh princess what 19
yeah i think michael jackson was 1958 as
well
and he died 2009. i remember when that
happened
because it was i still have my space
and someone said it online both of those
deaths it's like you just you're like oh
okay people are lying
you know what i mean
yeah okay
because that also happened a lot people
used to just release fake articles
saying like oh someone so died yeah and
they didn't that's what
that's why there was a lot of confusion
when paul walker died because i think a
week before there were articles going
around saying he was that he died and he
came out he was like no i didn't die and
then he died yeah they did for that car
accident and people were like no that
one was fake like no today like happened
right now
kind of wild timing it really was wild
wild
r.i.p paul walker what else you got all
right so this is pretty spooky it's
pretty scary this
chimpanzee
at the zoo
attacked this man no that's a pongo
pigmasis
what word what
how do you say that
yeah go ahead spell it out is it not a
orangutan look how big it is wait say it
again say it again are we pronouncing it
correctly congo pig macy's wow look at
it
you only don't get your rainbow i know
that it's because [ __ ] uh remember
that movie dunstan checks in no
oh yeah you know what i'm talking about
what was it called toasted trucks
this feels like that one movie you
recommended angus or whatever shout out
to angus oh yeah that's actually this
reminds me of that is it is it p
o n g o p y g m a s
g w w s no no i'm already lost we should
have p slowly and punch c y g
this is just like
keep your eyes closed while you're
spilling this too because he has it
pulled up
m-a-c-i-a-s so so p-o-n-g-o-p-y-g-m-a
he was actually super close
they ain't bad that ain't bad pongo pig
moose that's not bad i think you
pronounce it roger that is
hey
i didn't go to pronouncing school all
right
your latin was okay though it was
terrible
uh
that video is wild though it's pretty
funny but it is crazy i missed the
beginning was he he was taunting this
thing i think he got too close yeah like
he definitely shouldn't have had been
reaching his arms out
and look what but look how strong it is
oh my god that's so terrifying that is
terrifying i would have just took my
shirt off take your shirt off yeah right
now where's your leg oh yeah you can't
he's on the single now he's on the side
break it down here hi crotch hi crotch
then he wraps his legs around his he's
got his
arms wrapped and
it's going to bite you i would like not
touch the cage i'm scared of everything
right now look at it
oh my god what happened to the man is he
okay
uh
we never found out
i could accept that
that's the most
that happens all the time with viral
videos there you don't get the ending
like they end and i'm like i gotta know
the aftermath i want to know where all
the members are do they have fans just
take his dick
yeah when he pulled the shirt he should
have just like got out of his shirt she
just slipped out of it
and show them
not to be a hater but
why is that camera there filming on the
bottom
you think the monkey set this up jim no
someone if someone pulled out a camera
you had the zoo your friend goes up
if someone pulled out a camera like oh
[ __ ] look what's going on yeah they were
probably trying to be wholesome recorded
memories no they planted the camera on
the bottom and then this happened i'm
just being real
i've watched hundreds of thousands of
videos doing current events i i have
like a you have your speculation yeah
exactly and that's
he does watch a lot of videos he has a
phd in viral videos
i would let this happen yeah look at
they try to kick the monkey away from
him
dale look at that determined face
what is it will you look up the strength
of a pongo pigman it's not a pound of
things though
it is i think that we just pulled it up
what that looks exactly like
whatever the hell you call it is a ring
it's just now actually no that does look
like yeah that does look like yeah isn't
it so uh look at the strength like the
strength of it
wait is that not yeah strength
wait have you guys seen the most
valuable primate no i don't know why i
just thought what i was trying to think
of the because there's he plays catcher
right no he's a hockey goalie or a
hockey player get out of here
bro they used to make some of the
wilderness
there is another movie where a monkey
plays a catcher i i'm almost positive
what was it what was the movie with the
dogs and the cat and they go
oh a home on the range no it's a whole
arrangement where like they get lost
it's like
oh homeward bound yeah that's what it is
it's like a pit bull a cat and a golden
retriever the glow retriever is like the
leader of the past
oh that was a good movie this is like
there's a real movie yeah you guys have
never seen this no i have not meatball
was a stunt double i feel like anything
they the same height
same facial hair same facial hair brush
we bought that stun double
shouts out earbuds
this reminds me of south park's parody
of rob schneider movies he's like yeah
rob schneider is a stapler
but that's about to change
[Laughter]
but yeah it's basically jack
was he like really good it's good
shoots a little harder
and he's about to take that made a whole
movie about this
when did they stop making trailers like
this with the narration i know
those are a peak
but yeah yeah it does have a stun double
though
that is [ __ ] hilarious
that's so good an airbucker just playing
basketball i love the movies where it
was like a little kid playing with the
pros
like uh like mike yeah uh what was the
key with the dude with the [ __ ] pitch
uh rookie there rookie of the year it
was another one i think there was only
two maybe
but there's more
it probably is how long we've been going
it's been a while hour seven perfect
is that purple
plug
some stuff i think any time we hit an
hour then we can go out
yeah that's fine uh where would i be
next
oh
rhode island oh yeah i'll be in rhode
island sorry i'm still on uh uk yeah uk
time sorry about that
june 24th the 25th
comedy connection in rhode island i will
be there i don't know if i have fans out
there but you did it it'd be nice do i
really yeah oh okay it'd be nice if
y'all you know to come out you know
support me and just laugh at my stuff
even if it's not funny otherwise it's
funny it's all funny otherwise i'll kick
you in the throat uh then what else i
got
oh that's like later oh later on like
when the fall hits uh yeah i guess i'm
in irvine at irvine improv can i come
yeah you totally come on yeah i'm gonna
go oh you guys can't find hell yeah
everybody
and all that stuff and in chicago people
have been reaching out to me about
chicago
i'll be
out there september 15th through the
17th
and then i think that's all i got
so tickets at chapellelacey.com
damn oh what hey listen this does move
tickets by the way
uh this podcast hell yeah because uh
there's someone a couple people in
london they're like i heard it on cats
after darkness oh that's cool so yeah so
it's actually cool so thank you guys you
know thank you
spell's not quitting hell yeah
you can just see all this tension to
leave
you're not the only one that has a live
show irvine improv me and the two guys i
talk about reality tv with are joining
kate casey
july 13th really
dude awesome man is that your first ever
uh we did one with the water cooler like
chris locksmith oh okay uh producer for
the show one time we had a live show but
uh this is gonna be a lot more people
hopefully
that's so cool so cool yeah and there
might be a housewife there she's not
putting her on the bill because it's not
guaranteed
can we can we know which
uh city housewife uh i i think uh orange
county oh okay i don't know yeah that
makes sense irvine yeah
um but yeah so come out irvine improv
july 13th and also on uh
on our patreon patreon.com another
podcast network i told shin and it's not
something i want to share on like public
uh
uh but i told him a pretty crazy story i
think he'd vouch it was it's so crazy
yeah it's so crazy i was in the
tenderloin area searching through most
people uh in san francisco yeah yeah oh
okay
that's like that's like the bay area
skid row yeah that's the bay area skid
row we can't say much about it though
right because you want to save for that
same for patreon yeah all right i like
birds it's an insane story though i like
that photo
who you guys got
back there uh you can check me out on
my instagram georgeharris48 or my
youtube channel go george go
you guys have been helping a lot and i
love it i've been getting up so many
nice comments and you guys are the
sweetest
shout
uh you catch me on instagram at teen on
only fans at teen and i do vlogs now so
check those out just type in my name
that's about it meatball
uh
you can just find me on instagram
oh yes yep i i booked my ticket so i
will be with chappelle on june 24th to
the 25th so make sure to come out
and uh you can just find me on instagram
at see parallel 6 and that's about it
also welcome back thank you we missed
you guys
i know you're at that wedding are they
still together yes oh yeah dude that's a
good question
um
yes but for now for now
but uh i will say this me and my friend
like left notes like in the car just be
funny mine was like light-hearted and my
other friend like it was funny at first
and then he got like a little too like
cutthroat on it and he made her cry
after and i felt bad
yeah
and i won't name him but the one thing
that like also like i really [ __ ]
hated about it was he only gave him five
dollars
that is
what a dick dude that's how much he
didn't like her yeah
that's like oh yeah that was me at the
wedding
huh wait what did he say
hurt my heart all right so a few things
okay uh first of all thank you to
everyone that um
for the feedback remember i do i'm doing
a collaboration with that
into the end oh yes
so we had like four different designs
and then
there's over 600 people that commented
with their votes which is amazing so
thank you guys for that and then they
they the majority was for the lantern
design so i just need one more thing i'm
putting a video up by the time this
comes out the video will be up but if
it's better on a black t-shirt or a
white t-shirt that's all i need to know
and then obviously my youtube channel
chinsy instagram's chincy and thank you
so much for all the support and thank
you for all following cats after dark so
cool yeah yeah this is kind of cool it's
actually fun for us yeah yeah we have a
blast doing it
oh yeah yeah good [ __ ] oh wait wait one
more
me and austin little brows
we should be touring
so in texas in august and then
ohio and august and then texas again in
october oh you guys are booked what
parts of texas uh dallas
austin
and then portsmouth ohio okay yeah now
austin show should be good i love house
texas oh while you're in austin go get
pizza from this place called home slice
it's so good i got eggplant pizza there
for the first time is it it's my
favorite uh i i believe the uh eggplant
one is vegetarian but i just i didn't
know that eggplant pizza was a thing i
guess it's really popular on the east
coast yeah but not here on the west
coast it was the first time i ever had
eggplant pizza the way it's supposed to
be made it's so [ __ ] good it's my
favorite pizza topping now okay i wrote
it down it's my favorite and i can't get
it anywhere in california yeah the one
thing i love about texas is you can
always count it count on its uh food
they know how to eat like like they know
how to cook every city in texas like you
can always [ __ ] count on
i love great food there texas is my
second home yeah yeah
i've been eating vegetarian food i've
had like i went to a restaurant and i
had for the first time like tacos mm-hmm
it's supposed to be like apa store or
caracada yeah did it taste drinking
great
i forgot what it was
but it tasted so good huh i was no i had
that was the same oh jackfruit yeah yeah
i'm not sure what they used for the
vegetable but it was so freaking good
yeah do you feel good oh that's it it
felt good yeah yeah yeah
yeah pizza is really good damn seven
thousand
plus google reviews
is the best thing i've ever found before
that's awesome it's so good please go
there oh yeah definitely
hell yeah well that's us signing off
what you some funny people
no not at all i'll kick you in the
throat
yeah i'm back i'm back
he's back in america hey i'm in
different and i'm i'm different in
london yeah i'm really nice
to to little people you know i realized
a little bit
[Music]
all right thank you guys for listening
bye see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you